rien je m'appelle 1 à marco va je suis
danseuse au théâtre pour enfants de
nathalie assad samus coup je m'appelle
ivan titoff
je suis le mari d'anna et son partenaire
sur scène je viens de gagner un prix au
concours international de balai
arabesques
nous voulions participer à un concours à
sotchi
on va au concours ou pas telle que type
est maintenant notre participation n'est
pas évidente tout cela à cause de moi
j'en ai vraiment marre c'est dur
psychologiquement
[Musique]
ban a tu veux que je t'ai non merci
j'arrive déjà à le faire moi même je me
suis blessé à un pied
ce n'est pas la première fois je m'étais
déjà cassé le même pied l'autre pied un
bras aussi chez les artistes de bâle est
le plus souvent c'est des tendinites des
entorses aux chevilles chez moi c'est
toujours des fractures elle est
extrêmement doué quand il s'agit de se
casser un pied pourrait elle court dans
les coulisses et ska un pied c'est sa
spécialité anna pour nous les gens de
bâle est le plus frustrant c'est de se
casser un pied sans raison ouanna oui
c'est tellement triste et frustrant les
spectateurs l'ont vu il n'y avait pas de
spectateurs c'était une répétition
c'était une répétition c'est encore plus
frustrant que quand ça arrive pendant le
spectacle de danse pas dans ce spectacle
hp web ce jour là je ne me sentais pas à
ma place au théâtre
le plus triste c'est que je me suis
cassé le pied un mois avant le concours
de sotchi où nous avions voulu
participer avec mon mari je nous ai
handicapés tous les goûts
à midi commence pipolino ivan y joue le
rôle du comte cerise dans le deuxième
acte
je devais danser magnolia mais voilà le
souci qui m'est arrivé je quittais la
scène c'était tout noir je n'ai pas vu
l'appareil d'éclairage que quelqu'un
avait si intelligemment 1001 des
projecteurs étaient ici l'on est bas
mais je regardais au loin inspiré et je
n'ai pas aperçu l'obstacle tacots je me
suis blessé au pied
c'était fort je me suis cognée contre ce
truc ça fait vraiment très mal et bien
sûr qu'ils ont trouvé un remplacement
pour moi car varas héros va à danser le
rôle de magnolia pour el ma fracture a
été en quelque sorte une occasion de
danser un rôle principal dans le ballet
s'allume à varvara léana savard et
pompiers ça va bien je n'ai plus mal
demain je vais enlever le plâtre et nous
allons probablement participer au
concours avec ivan dans un mois tu fais
les folles quoi on va voir tu ferais
mieux de te rétablir
j'ai tellement envie je crois que tu
ferais mieux de soigner ton pied pendant
tout l'été et puis de commencer la
nouvelle saison détendue parce que sinon
d'accord je vais voir une fois le plâtre
enlevés si tout va bien
comme tu veux
décider elle même de venir au théâtre
avec des béquilles j'étais contre mais
la retenue en ça ne sert à rien elle
voulait vraiment me soutenir
oh mon dieu
je ressentais des forces en moi j'ai
posé des béquilles et j'ai fait quelques
fouetter
l'essentiel c'est que ivan n'ai rien vu
après midi tu ne peux pas faire ça j'ai
le droit de rien faire
encore un peu et je suis prête au
concours
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
non
voilà les chances là par ici
[Musique]
du coup je n'étais pas habitué à être
derrière les coulisses sans me préparais
à mon entrée sans m'échauffer au moins
j'ai pu être utile à quelqu'un ça on va
chanter maintenant
[Musique]
enfin nous
il refusait à jim que pitch moi la porte
ou venant à ta mouchetés yves milbeau
n'y passe quand il
[Musique]
dubai qu'à démissionner
sachez que vous avez jamais entendu
chanter les danseurs de ballet c'est
horrible c'est atroce ils n'ont pas
d'oreille musicale une bonne voie
j'espère que personne ne nous a entendu
chanter dans la salle nous aurions mieux
fait de danser selon l'idée du
chorégraphe les artistes de balès chante
dans ce spectacle on nous a donné le
micro et tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
occupés chantait la chanson
[Musique]
le prince citron est excellent c'est
tout les citrons sont excellents oh oui
[Musique]
c'est qui c'est toi ivan commença à qui
vous ne reconnaissez pas le comte cerise
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
l'essentiel c'est que le chapeau ne
tombe pas
un matin comment il tient il ya beaucoup
d'épinglés à les épingles
je crois qu'ils pèsent plus que ma tête
famille que je suis certes plus à l'aise
quand je danse avec anna une nouvelle
partenaire c'est comme une nouvelle
langue
il faut la prendre à nouveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien
j'étais un peu nerveuse au début bien
sûr
après tout est calme et merci beaucoup
j'ai compris qu'il fallait me rétablir
le plus vite possible
revenir sur scène et faire passer le
message à ivan que nous devrions aller
au concours à sotchi alors tu vas bien
oui tu as été excellent tu m'emmènera
demain à l'hôpital bien sûr je vote
enlève le plâtre oui bien sûr nous
allons encore danser à notre concours
sur un pied sur un pied bonjour ne
dérangeait pas ah non je crois que non
les pieds sont déformés ces
professionnels
vous avez toujours eu cette petite bosse
ici bah oui comme ça s'il est sensible
mais ça ne fait pas mal
sensibiliser oui d'après les propos du
médecin
je ne comprenais pas si mon pied était
guéri comme quand j'avais l'impression
que je pourrais déjà marcher sur mes
deux pieds
on m'a mis dans un fauteuil et emmenés
faire la radio
d'accord allez
je ne veux pas rester ici
elle saute déjà ok j'attends je crois
que c'est guéri depuis longtemps je le
sens
j'en ai tellement marre quand quelqu'un
qui travaille beaucoup physiquement qui
bouge activement tout le temps à des
entraves c'est très dur
psychologiquement je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi le médecin n'avait pas dit tout
de suite que tout allait bien il a
examiné la radio pendant longtemps
apparemment quelque chose n'allait pas à
présent nous voyons les signes de
guérison
la fracture s'est ressoudé du coup à
neuf à nous quitter sans plâtrier d'une
fois il faut marcher avec une canne le
reste du traitement consistera retrouver
l'élasticité des ligaments
combien de temps je pourrai chargé le
pied en charge totale we re commencer
les entraînements
oui je pense qu'il faudrait trois
semaines pour le rétablissement du temps
donner votre compétence professionnelle
je crois que ces trois semaines pour
laisser le fauteuil par là
je peux leur jambe et comme ça je vais
en sortir c'est pas grave merci beaucoup
on saute pas les propos du médecin ont
mis fin à l'espoir de participer au
concours à sotchi dans mon stock parce
que pour le concours il fallait répéter
et répéter beaucoup je n'en n'aurai pas
eu le temps tu n'y vas ce concours ou
pas allons-y mon coeur deux semaines
mais ça tu as dit que tu pourrais
travailler à pleine capacité
seulement dans un mois il fallait
informer le comité d'organisation du
concours que nous ne pourrions pas y
participer c'était dur de l'accepter
vas-y envoi je ne peux pas y aller sans
toi il y aura d'autres concours tu te
rétablir a bien sûr on leur apprendra à
danser j'aurais pu participer au
concours tout seul j'étais en bonne
forme à la fin de la saison mais je ne
peux pas laisser ça ici tout seul
j'ai donc renoncé à participer
[Musique]
venez plus souvent bonjour ma belle
bonjour bonjour
dis moi comment ça va bien écoute
l'essentiel c'est de se rappeler une
idée simple nous sommes des sportifs
d'endurance pas sur 100 m nous avons
besoin d'avoir une vie longue et saine
sur scène soigne toi merci bonne chance
tu es très talentueuse et gentil merci
j'avais encore un peu mal au pied au
début de la saison mais ce jour là
j'avais la répétition de l'oiseau bleu
c'est une technique et une charge
absolument différentes 1 à supporter un
tutu je lui enlève on va répéter la
lumière la lumière oui
mais elena m'a dit anna je crois qu'elle
n'a pas dit concrètement moi même a dit
seulement que ce serait le lac des
cygnes
si j'avais su je me serai préparé je me
préparer au rôle de l'oiseau bleu mais
j'ai appris qu'il faudrait danse et la
lumière
je n'étais pas prête
je ne me rappelais pas l'ordre les
aspects physiques et techniques
c'était absolument impossible après le
congé la fracture on va rire
en fait je ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir
tout faire maintenant je ferai ce que je
pourrais nous nous attendions à l'oiseau
bleu mais il faudra faire quelque chose
de plus difficile c'est plus intense
effort la lumière ses plus grands plus
compliqué il faut le faire à da ce qui
compte c'est que ce soit tout va bien
elle aurait dû le danser à la première
mais elle s'est blessée
c'est ce même rôle la lumière qu'elle
devait jouer à la première
maintenant elle va le danser dans son
premier spectacle elle s'est rétablie
elle est de nouveau dans la troupe tout
va bien qu'est ce que cela veut dire
vladimir petrovic bien de dire à nakheel
prennent soin de son pied et il lui
donne tout de suite le rôle de la
lumière qui est bien plus difficile que
celui de l'oiseau bleu elle s'est cassé
le pied en dansant ce n'est pas du tout
logique mais que faire elle ne voulait
pas que j'interviens dos
[Musique]
il est stipulé dans notre contrat que
l'artiste n'a pas le droit de solliciter
un rôle ou de renoncer à un rôle c'est
pourquoi je n'avais aucune possibilité
de protester et je répétais ce qu'on
m'avait dit comme je pouvais comment
demain attention anna ne va pas fort
maintenant elle avait bien travaillé les
deux rôles et j'ai pleuré quand tout
s'est passé ancien elle n'a pas pu
danser
non je vous le monde a pleuré
m
il y avait je vois que tu es fatigué tu
commences à boiter on va finir
yann moix ça va tout répéter après la
pause
anna fait très attention à son pied à la
fin elle a commencé à bois j'espère
qu'elle n'a pas vraiment eu de grand
stress c'est juste que la répétition n'a
pas été aussi efficace qu'on l'avait
espéré
[Musique]
ce jour là c'était en effet ma première
parce que je n'avais pas pu danser ce
rôle au cours de la saison précédente à
cause de la fracture du pied
c'est ma couronne tout le monde
l'admirent mais à vrai dire elle est
très lourde
quoique très belle on dit que sur scène
elle a l'air très bien ce n'est pas
évident comme on l'accroché spectacle en
plus je dois la m pendant le spectacle
et pas avant et c'est à dire je me cache
derrière les coulisses et je dois vite
me mettre la belle couronne
ça va bien egler je joue l'eau en
briques
je dois être très doux qui métillon chef
aussi souple que je puisse être j'ai mal
aux pieds maintenant mais ce n'est pas
assez fort pour ne pas danser
il ya des choses qui m'inquiète vraiment
mais je vais réfléchir d'une manière
positive et espérer que tout ira bien
je sais qu'elle a un peu mal aux pieds
on ne peut rien y faire c'est juste
qu'elle aime danser et le plaisir de la
danse dépasse la douleur
tout va bien oui je veux qu'on mette
encore plus de lacs
[Musique]
je pense que ça suffit oui c'est tout
sinon je ressemblerais un sapin de noël
merci merci c'est pour rendre mon image
encore plus proche de l'eau des
paillettes chez lui à vrai dire je
n'aime pas les paillettes mais s'il faut
les mettre pour le rôle on fait tenir
une telle que ça c'est beau si je
pouvais bien danser avec toute cette
beauté
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un autre théâtre tu
es jeune et il faut dire bonjour à l'ema
timide
bonjour nous sommes venus avec plaisir
dans ce théâtre pour enfants c'est le
meilleur théâtre
bonjour vous savez quel le spectacle que
vous allez voir
non l'oiseau bleu
[Musique]
le spectacle va commencer
pourquoi on est en retard
c'est pas clair allez il faut commencer
c'est ce que je dis et j'ai déjà chaud
partout moi aussi trop échauffés
tu n'as pas vu anna comment je n'ai pas
vu un an
je les ai vus il ya quarante minutes pas
mal ça veut dire qu'il est toujours au
théâtre elle ne s'est pas enfui
[Musique]
ça y est c'est déjà calme a depuis
longtemps
et merde à tout le monde un jeu franc il
est resté quelques minutes avant
d'entrer sur scène et je n'arrivais pas
à faire bouger mon coup j'ai dû prendre
froid pendant la répétition et c'est
vannes avait une pommade et il mon ami à
moi
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
son boulot
[Musique]
à ma tête à tête
oui c'est bon comme ça
[Musique]
mais celle ci après
je vais essayer les épingles très bien
mais les doutes et sur ana
ça tient je crois ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas d'accident non c'est juste que les
bandes sont trop glissante et ressortent
tout le temps c'est parce qu'elles ont
été lavés je crois
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
pièce c'est la lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
c'est là que je me suis blessé
est-ce que l'appareil était là oui
c'est comme ça les artistes ont froid
avant le spectacle j'ai le nez rouge qui
coule c'est pas grave on va tenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a déjà terminé ana non j'ai encore la
marche
j'suis pas de ce côté je sai pompiers a
commencé à me lâcher vers la fin du
spectacle je boitais non il restait
encore la marche finale où je devais
participer
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
félicitations tout le monde c'était
magnifique
la saison a bien débuté vous avez été
excellent bravo merci j'ai dû prendre
froid hier quelque part je t'avais dit
de bientôt couvrir il me suis habillé tu
étais la seule avec le dos nu je les ai
vus j'ai même demandé à ivan pourquoi tu
as bien aimé était le dos nu merci
servat lecouls
il m'a disputé parce que je n'étais pas
assez couverte ir en dansant il voulait
que tu danses avec tous tes vêtements
d'accord avec toi
oui venez venez merci beaucoup merci à
vous c'était un plaisir pour nous merci
beaucoup merci encore une fois merci à
vous je peux vous embrasser bien sûr
c'est un plaisir vraiment venez encore
d'accord merci beaucoup merci regarde on
a encore offert des fleurs qu'ils soient
les spectateurs les spectateurs super je
t'avais dit que tu es magnifique je ne
croyais même pas que c'était fini que
c'était une réussite
je ne savais pas encore ce qu'en dit
raymond principal spectateurs et
critiques en ma mère elle m'appelle ras
plus tard et me dire à tous non éthiques
mais techniquement j'ai assuré alors tu
es heureuse je suis folle de joie
[Musique]